foreign
so we're in the middle of a fierce
debate about how artificial intelligence
will change Human Society but have you
thought about how AI will transform your
relationship to the non-human world
so these are bioacoustic recorders and
I've spent years studying how scientists
use devices like this
combined with AI to listen to The Hidden
Sounds of Nature and decode non-human
communication
hidden sounds because much acoustic
Communication in nature occurs in the
high ultrasound above your hearing range
or in the Deep infrasound
below your hearing range
so I'm going to play a sound I want you
to listen and try to guess who or what
this is
so that was a bat that was bad
ultrasound recorded above your hearing
range but slowed down so you could hear
so that was an advertisement call from
the peak of The Mating Season scientists
can decode these calls so let's sample
back to English translation would be and
I quote
pay attention I'm a pipas trellis
natuzibat specifically male my name is X
I am Landing here and we share a common
social identity and common communication
pool
for a pickup line by avat not bad
so scientists have recorded millions of
bad vocalizations like this and they've
decoded many of them using Ai and
they've revealed that bats have dialects
that they pass down from one generation
to the next and that baby bats learn to
speak just like you did by listening to
the adults around them and babbling back
until they speak adult bat
so bats have far more complex
communication than we knew and they're
only one of many examples listen to this
so those are orcas who live right here
in the Sailor sea
scientists can decode individual Orca
calls using Ai and they've revealed that
orcas also passed down their dialects
from one generation to the next
so it turns out that orcas and bats are
not the only creatures that make
ultrasound moths mice beetles rats even
some of our smaller primate cousins like
this tars here
at the other end in the Deep infrasound
elephants and whales tigers and some
birds make sound
so when we first learn about these
secret sounds of the world we're often
surprised because humans tend to believe
that what we cannot perceive does not
exist
and so we miss a lot
one of my favorite examples is this
peacock so to you this looks like a
visual mating display and it is
but this peacock is also making very
loud infrasound with its tail which you
cannot hear but female pecans can and it
is an important factor in their mating
decisions so this peacock is giving a
rock concert
now we have lived with peacocks for
Millennia but we only just figured this
out
scientists also used to think that
Turtles were voiceless and mother
Turtles abandoned their nests after
laying their eggs but we've just
discovered that baby Amazonian turtles
communicate through their shells before
they hatch to coordinate the moment of
their birth and then follow their
mother's calls to Safety in the water
even creatures without ears are
exquisitely sensitive to sound
so this is a coral larva
when Coral larvae are born usually at a
mass spawning event a few days after the
full moon they wash out to sea so
scientists used to think that these
little larvae these tiny dots that you
see here were helpless randomly pushed
around by wind and waves and currents
but it turns out that Coral larvae are
acoustically attuned they can hear the
sounds of healthy reefs they can hear
the sound of their home Reef their
mother reef and they swim back home
across miles of open ocean
so these are tiny creatures with no
central nervous system so but we think
they do that with these hairs that you
see on the outside of their bodies
they're a lot like the hairs inside your
ears that are enabling you to listen to
me right now so you can think of a coral
larva a little bit like an inside out
ear except that its sense of hearing is
profoundly more sensitive than your own
because they hear what their entire
bodies
even our planet makes sound volcanoes
earthquakes sound so low and strong and
powerful they travel very far passing
through soil and stone and even solid
walls listen to this hydrothermal vent
deep under the ocean
so in nature sound is everywhere and
silence is an illusion
so scientists are also listening to the
vast extent of inter-species
communication
So This Bat is using ultrasound to hunt
this moth it's echolocation beam is
locked onto its prey but the moth is
also emitting ultrasound it's jamming
the bat sonar
in an attempt to escape
this plant is also emitting ultrasound
which varies depending on its condition
scientists have trained an algorithm to
listen to this plant simply by listening
it can detect with about 70 percent
accuracy whether the plant is healthy
dehydrated or injured so this is
peer-reviewed research by the way
so we cannot hear these sounds but we
think many insects can
does this mean that humans could use
digital Tech to one day communicate with
other species well some scientists think
so and they're using machine learning to
try to decode the Acoustics of other
species so they're teams of computer
scientists and linguists and biologists
working on decoding sperm whale
bioacoustics
they're also building entire
dictionaries so there's an elephant
dictionary with thousands of sounds
elephants for example have a specific
signal for honeybee
so I'd love to share just one of these
sounds with you it was recorded at a
moment of great joy and celebration the
birth of a new baby
[Music]
so the further we listen across the Tree
of Life the more complex inter-species
communication would be listen to this
honeybee
now listen to this honeybee Queen
[Music]
so you thought you knew what honeybees
sounded like okay honeybee communication
is incredibly complex it's acoustic
positional spatial vibrational the queen
has her own signals so scientists are
encoding these signals into robots this
robot is attempting but not succeeding
to communicate with the hive the bees
mostly ignore or attack it but
one day we hope the inventors hope that
this robot will communicate well enough
to allow scientists to monitor the
health of the hive
now would that be a good thing
some believe that interspecies
communication would help Foster respect
and empathy for nature others believe
that it is profoundly disrespectful and
unethical to eavesdrop and engage in
this way
and there could be a really big downside
listen to this Robin
so that was not actually a robin that
was a deep fake
created by an artist Daisy Ginsburg
using AI clever beautiful but think of
the potential for misuse by hunters or
poachers
interspecies communication needs strong
ethical guard rails
and anyway maybe it's a bit
self-centered to think other species
would even want to communicate with us
so what if we were to use bioacoustics
for something of immediate practical
value like doing something about our
massive biodiversity crisis let's go
back to the coral reefs listen to this
healthy Reef sound
foreign
pretty Lively right but coral reefs are
disappearing if you were to go to most
coral reefs today you'd hear something
like this
it's like a ghost town of the sea when
we lose species we lose voices when we
lose Landscapes we also lose soundscapes
there is a ray of Hope the healthy Reef
sounds that you just heard can be used
to regenerate coral reefs
scientists are doing this it's a bit
like music therapy for nature so this is
not going to solve all the problems
coral reefs face notably climate change
but if we can address the massive
epidemic of noise pollution that is
harming and killing Marine creatures we
could use bioacoustics to restore some
biodiversity
bioacoustics would also help protect
animals on the move
so this is this baby well was killed by
a ship tragically this is a common cause
of death of North Atlantic right whales
one of the most endangered species in
the world
so to address this scientists are now
launching a new bioacoustics program off
the east coast of North America to
triangulate the locations of whales and
convey the information to ship's
captains in real time the ships then
have to slow down stop move out of the
way not a single right whale has died of
a ship strike in this Zone since this
program was launched this
so this may be the thing that saves this
species so think about it a few decades
ago we were harpooning these whales
nearly to Extinction today we've
invented a technology that allows a
community of less than 400 whales simply
by singing to guide the movements of
tens of thousands of ships in a
watershed that's home to tens of
millions of people
one day these whale Lanes may be
everywhere in the oceans
for the orcas who live here in the
Salish sea this would be just in time
because there are only a few dozen left
a final thought
about 400 years ago the inventors of the
microscope were astonished to discover
the microbial World they had no idea
their invention would lead to the
discovery of DNA and the ability to
manipulate the code of life around the
same time the inventors of the telescope
were gazing up at the stars not knowing
their invention would allow Humanity to
look back in time to the origins of the
universe
Optics decenters Humanity within the
solar system within the cosmos
bioacoustics decenters Humanity within
the Tree of Life
our commonality is greater than we knew
now today we're using bioacoustics to
protect species and decode their
communication but tomorrow I believe
we'll be using bioacoustics combined
with machine intelligence to explore the
frontiers of biological intelligence
many biological intelligences are very
different than our own but they're no
less worthy of exploration
and maybe one day in a speculative
future instead of a human here on stage
maybe bioacoustics would enable an orca
to give a TED Talk
why not sharing Orca stories about
dodging ships and seismic blasts and
human Hunters stories about Desperately
Seeking the last remaining salmon
stories about trying to survive on this
beautiful planet in this crazy moment in
our era of untethered human creativity
and unprecedented environmental
emergency now those would be ideas worth
spreading
[Applause]
thank you